Amber Heard and Elon Musk's romance is  heating up check out the pair hanging  out together in Queensland Australia the  Tesla CEO was there visiting his  ladylove who's on location filming  Aquaman we're loving their sweet PDA  their arms adorably wrapped around one  another I'm very happy despite claims  amber and Elon were just friends a  source tells et they've actually been  dating for a while the source said that  the actress isn't looking to settle down  but she's having fun with their blooming  relationship explaining quote Elon is  very attentive to Amber which is  something she looks for in a partner  kind of chapter both stars are recently  single  Elon filed for divorce from wife Talulah  Riley in late 2016 while Amber's divorce  from Johnny Depp was finalized in  January  [Music]